the dynamics at the lower levels and
only follow the microscopic the more
comprehensive theories are all
so there is some answer to the question
if you take every ad of the mix up a
person and reconstitute in exactly the
same version somewhere else what will
happen and that answer is unique if you
believe the laws of atomic physics and
therefore either the higher level is
entailed or the laws of atomic physics
are wrong those are your only two
choices
I expect that most of us think that we
don't know that there aren't alternative
life chemistry's so now a really
interesting question is if we went to
another planet in another galaxy and
found life-forms from the different
chemistry would we expect nevertheless
economics would be the same and that
their psychology would be the same
questions that's the question about
about whether the special Sciences have
generalizations which are not seen as a
model we've been working with is a sort
of entailment of the chemistry by the
physics and the biology by the chemistry
and the Nahanni
to the poetry that's a sort of very
simplistic idea of naturalism and this
is other possibility that you can get
depending on the initial conditions
basically are local conditions you can
get divergent mid-level theories this
brings up I think something that we have
not distinguished well and that is and I
listen to physicists or people talking
from a physics point of view I have a
conception of emergence or non-emergency
that is synchronic that is oh this is
the way the world is and there's the
small parts of the big parts and they're
all linked together
the term emergence i think implicitly is
about time and we're history members
certainly in biology history maps
biology is about the accumulation of
constraints and differences and
accidents for that matter and how the
accidents change the conditions
for the future history manners in that
sense I one of the problems I have is I
don't I don't actually think that a
concept of emergence makes a lot of
interesting sense synchronically I do
think it makes a lot of sense
diatonically across time as things
change when we say something is new I'm
not talking about something is new up at
a higher level versus a low level it
wasn't here before
why wasn't it here before why wasn't it
expressed in the preconditions why is it
expressed in the post conditions so I
don't actually everything I've heard
does not bother me because I don't see
any incompatibility between you know the
fundamental laws of physics where's that
relationship no I don't think I wanna
say I don't think the idea of new
universal laws is the right way to think
about it I think new historical
conditions are the ways to think about
it I think that new complexes of
constraints so that the laws aren't
expressed the same way on the planet
earth as they are on the planet on the
planet Mars I think that's what's
different and that's why we have the
kinds of differences we have here I
think that's a historical contingency
issue
nothing new there they're everywhere
some planets there's never any
instantiation and others it comes along
here and it comes along yeah and that
gets back to my question of couldn't it
be the case that on one planet from a
historical accident they went through a
carbon-based life form then they went
through a sort of singularity and they
made they made a silicon electronic
robotics agents that were first there
their avatars their surrogates and then
the carbon-based life dies out and you
got you come to the planet and it's all
silicon based forms replicating so forth
and the economics holds I mean small
supply and demand still hopes and now
that suggests that the laws of economics
really aren't dependent on
being walked up through chemistry and I
mean this historically they're walked up
through but but if if they're going to
if they're going to turn out to be
applicable independently of the
chemistry of the life-forms
you